dude I cannot believe we are in Japan
right now we've been talking about this
since since before the pandemic right
I wonder if we're gonna see one of those
TV Crews
you've never seen that show
you being serious right now
no it's called
and they greet people at the airport
they give them like custom tours
dude bathroom
oh Japanese toilets
okay let's go
wait is that a sink
it's not a toilet you idiot
what a flusher
you know what is the sink this is
Janet's closet you stick your mop in
there and then you step on the flusher
and it cleans the mop off for you
so you don't have to carry around one of
those buckets that you have to squat
down and crank
that's what I've been telling you
that's what I've been telling you Japan
is like a generation ahead of us
I saw him I know he was wearing a suit
I got it in Japan the janitors must wear
suits too
Japanese uniforms
I don't know about this stuff